♪ ♪
>> I CAN TELL YOU WHAT’S GOING
TO HAPPEN.
WE HAVE A SLEEPY GUY IN A
BASEMENT OF THE HOUSE.
THAT THE PRESS IS GIVING A FREE
PASS, WHO DOESN’T WANT TO DO
DEBATES BECAUSE OF COVID.
LOTS OF THINGS ARE HAPPENING,
RIGHT?
AND I WATCHED A COUPLE OF BIDS
OF HIS AND I SAY, I LOOK FORWARD
TO THIS BUT THEY ARE KEEPING
HIM SHELTERED BECAUSE OF THE
CORONAVIRUS.
AND HE’S NOT MOVING AROUND, HE’S
NOT MOVING TOO MUCH.
>> Bret: FORMER VICE PRESIDENT
BIDEN OBVIOUSLY SHELTERED IN
DELAWARE DOING A NUMBER OF
INTERVIEWS AND A LOT OF LOCAL TV
ACTUALLY COME OUT LOOKING AT THE
LATEST POLLS AND STATES,
FOX NEWS POLL’S THEY HAVE
JOE BIDEN LEADING DONALD TRUMP
IN FLORIDA, MICHIGAN,
PENNSYLVANIA.
IF WE WILL BRING BACK THE PANEL,
JASON, STARTING WITH THE OPIATE
OF THE STATE OF THE
RACE AND WITH THE PRESIDENT IS
TALKING ABOUT THEIR AND HE’S
CONDEMNINGCLIMBING UP IN THEPOLL
AND ABOUT AS MUCH.
>> YEAH, I THINK ALL THINGS
CONSIDERED IS PROBABLY SATISFIED
WITH HOW THINGS ARE GOING AND
HE’S OBVIOUSLY IN A POSITION NO
OTHER CANDIDATE HAS BEEN IN
BEFORE WHERE HE IS ONLY BEEN
KEPT INSIDE BY THE PANDEMIC BUT
HE’S RAISING A TON OF MONEY.
HE STILL HANGING IN THERE AND
LEADING A LOT OF SWING STATES
THAT ARE EXPECTED TO DECIDE THE
ELECTION AND ALL THINGS
CONSIDERED I THINK JOE BIDEN
PROBABLY THINKS HE’S DOING
ALL RIGHT.
>> Bret: HAROLD?
AND SPEAK OUT ONE OF THE MOTHER
TELLING NUMBERS ON THE DATA, A M
OF THE COUNTRY DOESN’T ALWAYS
BELIEVE THE PRESIDENT WHEN HE
SPEAKING.
MOLLIE GAVE A LITTLE BIT OF A
SENSE THAT WE ALL HAD TO MAYBE
AS TO WHY AND BIDEN, I’VE HEARD
SOME REPUBLICAN FRIENDS OF MY
SAY THAT HE’S INVISIBLE AND HE’S
WEAK AND IT’S THE IW STRATEGY
AND HE’S ALSO WINNING AND HE’S
WINNING IN THE IW IS WORKING IN
HIS FAVOR.
IF THIS WILL NOT LAST AND HE
WILL HAVE TO LAY OUT THE
ECONOMIC CLAIM HIS TEAM IS WORKI
ON AND HAVE A BIG BRAWL IN THE
SUMMER IN THE FALL AROUND HOW DO
WE MOVE THE COUNTRY FROM THIS
MOMENT AND HOW DO WE SEND IT
AWAY TO JASON’S POINT, GETTING
IT TO A BETTER AND STRONGER AND
VIBRANT PLACE AS A COUNTRY AND
NOT SPEND FOR SPENDING SAKE.
>> Bret: MOLLIE, FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT SAID THAT THIS
WAS ON THE FUND-RAISING CALL
THAT THE PRESIDENT WAS GOING TO
PUSH BACK THE ELECTION SOMEHOW.
IF NO EVIDENCE OF THAT AND DID
NOT GET CALLED ON IT REALLY
ABOUT THAT.
HE’S BEHIND THE EIGHT BALL WHEN
IT COMES TO FUND-RAISING VERSUS
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
WE GET CLOSER TO CLOSER THE HEAD
THOUGH HAD MOMENT.
>> THERE’S A LOT OF PRODUCTION
AND REMINDS ME A BIT OF 2016
WHEN THERE ARE SO MANY QUESTIONS
ASKED OF NOW PRESIDENT TRUMP
ABOUT WHETHER HE’S GOING TO
ACCEPT THE ELECTION RESULTS IF
HE LOST.
IT TURNED OUT TO BE THE MUCH
MORE PRESSING QUESTION THAT WE
COULD HAVE GOTTEN TO.
BUT THE PANDEMIC HAS REALLY
HELPED BIDEN CONSOLIDATING
SUPPORT BEHIND IT BUT NOW IT’S
VERY DIFFICULT FOR HIM TO
CAMPAIGN AND REALLY GET THE
MESSAGE OUT THERE AND IT’S A
MIXED BAG FOR HIM.
>> Bret: ALL RIGHT, 30 SECONDS
AND SO MOLLIE, HAROLD, JASON
GAETA JOE BIDEN’S VICE PRESIDENT
PICK AND I’M ONLY GIVING ONE I’M
NOT PLAYING THE CONCEDE OH, YOU
MAKE YOU MY CASINO.
IT MOLLIE FIRST.
>> AMY KLOBUCHAR, THE STRONG
CONTENDER AND MAKING HIS
CANDIDACY MAKE MORE SERIOUS.
>> Bret: HAROLD.
>> Bret: I’D HAVE TO GO WITH
GRETCHEN HERE TONIGHT.
>> Bret: REALLY, GRETCHEN,
DESPITE ALL THE PUSHBACK IN
MICHIGAN, YOU THINK SHE STILL
GOING TO COME?
>> I THINK SHE NEEDS TO WIN
MICHIGAN AND SHE HELPED DELIVER
THEIR AND AMY KLOBUCHAR IS
STRONG, BUT HE’S MISSING AND NOT
THE RIGHT GENDER BUDGET GRETCHEN
WOULD BE MY CHOICE.
>> Bret: ALL RIGHT, JASON?
>> I’M GOING TO GO WITH JANET
PAULUS ON THE OUTCOME OF
SECRETARY .
>> Bret: OKAY, PANEL,